let's let's talk about that wokeness
stuff though so uh we got this from CNN
business Netflix's world has been turned
upside down as stock plunges 35 I think
it's actually at 37 and then we got the
story from CNN business the magic is
gone for Disney investors this is from
April 19th just just yesterday and they
say that Netflix has plunged more than
40 percent and Disney is down 15 percent
ladies and gentlemen I would just like
to say
get well go broke indeed well that's
happening at Netflix they gave as much I
don't know what the actual deal was I've
seen 12. I've seen 50 million dollars to
the Obama's production operation I had
Netflix on the other day and who was
pushed at me Barack Obama
putting out some globalist nice
nounsense about parks and conservation
and all of that and you know I guess I'm
not allowed to say anything against
national parks but the point is it was
propaganda they're paying off a
left-wing politician who uh frankly
brings nothing in terms of creativity
other than
political activism and so Netflix is
focused on as you as you've highlighted
both in the fiction and non-fiction
categories propaganda and people are
turning it off and there are all sorts
of other reasons for it but if you're
going and the biggest reason in my view
and I say this only half jokingly is
that half the movies aren't American so
you're going oh this movie looks good
turns out it's in a foreign language or
in an accent that's hard to follow
because of the subtitles and you don't
want to watch it so it's garbage it's
leftists and it's not as the quality
they're supposed to be what's with this
weird overlap between the left and
sexually inappropriate content for
children or about children I I you know
that's curious because it's funny when
people come out and they're like hey we
don't want teachers talking to kids
about these adult matters it's the left
specifically that freaks out and says we
are being attacked by the right and I'm
like 60 of Democrats agree with these
bills in Florida and these other states
that kids should not be taught this
stuff off but you've got a big
um big mouth is that the show's right
yeah was just renewed for season seven
you know what that show is
it is it is voiced by adults but it is
about children going through puberty and
engaging in over apparently for seven
years they're going through puberty I
guess are they still in puberty years
they're just living really slow yo and
people who have not seen the show I I
like I've mentioned this before like I
think it's a messed up it is disgusting
I mean if you watched it I saw a couple
I saw a half an episode at my friend's
house yeah I walked out of the room I
couldn't it's just so disgusting they're
12 they're like 11 and 12 and they're
talking about having sex no no they're
not talking about it it's so gross
yeah yeah there's like a scene where the
kid goes into a stall and they this they
show it and I'm like what how is this
South Park did you know similar lewd and
crude jokes and those I'm just like oh
I'm not again I'm not even saying it's
gross like spectacly it's gross
psychologically yeah it's I couldn't let
myself even hear it because it was
twisted cuties so gross yep now so
that's why I don't have Netflix I'm like
yeah absolutely not no there's
absolutely no way I'll ever have a
Netflix subscription
um
I think part of it is that obviously you
know there are creepy people all over
the world and in all parties but if
you're a creepy person who wants to
normalize your disgusting sexual
perversions the Democratic party has
made it perfectly clear that they are a
safe bet for you and I think it's not
it's radicalism because they don't have
the moral Foundation of purity
for those that are familiar with the
moral foundations man I always try to
get them up out of my head there's care
fairness loyalty Purity Liberty and uh
one more is it a 40 or is Authority and
loyalty the same thing I'm gonna look it
up what's it called again the uh moral
foundations Jonathan height
h-a-i-d-t so liberals when they have
this moral foundations test you can take
it asks you questions some of these
questions are really disturbing and it
asks you like to what degree are you
okay with this thing right and it'll be
like there's one where it says
a daughter takes her father's old you
know war flag and use it as a rag to mop
the floor or whatever are you okay with
this and so you know these are the kinds
of questions it was Authority is the
sixth yeah yeah so it's liberty sanctity
which I believe is the Purity yeah
loyalty fairness care and Authority yes
and you said and that's five though
Liberty was added Liberty Liberty yeah
yeah that was the sixth one yeah
Libertarians only have Liberty this is
amazing they don't care about anything
other than let me do what I want me free
uh liberals only have care and fairness
so if you're if you're saying something
like children must be protected the
sanctity of of children and Purity
innocence Etc well you're probably not
going to be a liberal because they don't
have that in their minds they don't they
don't understand this as a moral
foundation so when you look at the moral
foundations test there are some
questions that are like outright
disturbing they're hard about like
teachers and kids I I don't I mean I
don't know if I would say tar you say
it's is that okay or not but some of
it's like you know an uncle I didn't
want to say this I can't even say these
things yeah but it's remarkable what
someone would have to say is okay in
order to actually get listed as a
liberal thing because I I get I get
listed as like you know libertarian
left-leaning or something like that in
these tests but I have a balance of you
know I have care and fairness is
relatively high and it kind of goes down
I'm like that kind of makes sense like
because I'm kind of in the middle but
you look at how liberals Rank and I'm
like what question did they say they
they were okay with because that's kind
of weird because they don't care about
it well I've said this before leftism is
essentially a synonym for social Decay
it's the word that we use to describe it
and when you think about values like
care and fairness those are the easiest
to make subjective so there's no I mean
that's not fair or I care about this
person what does that really mean at
bottom I disagree a little bit I think I
think you know a healthy Society has a
left and a right wing and the left is is
kind of experimental in a sense where it
is a bit chaotic and and you could
describe it in extreme sense as decay
but the right is supposed to keep things
in check so the left can be like hey we
want to try this we want to try that and
the right says no no no okay marijuana
marijuana legalization is tolerable you
know what I mean yeah so where I
disagree is that the the foundation of
the left in where we get these terms is
actually from the French Revolution and
what the left was doing was beheading
people murdering them trying to like
fundamentally restructure the society in
extremely disastrous ways so I agree
that there are people in in society who
the left would argue they identify with
or have a monopoly over when you're
talking about creative people or folks
who might be willing to challenge the
status quo in some way but that's not
what leftism is that's a that's a good
one spear man you made a good point
there there are guys that Occupy Wall
Street who who there's like one dude who
said that he it was his dream to be Rob
Spear and I'm like you know he died he
got his jaw blown off and they laid him
on a table for two days to die I love
they love it man well I love the idea I
go back to the library cop on Seinfeld
maybe dating myself but uh remember he
goes you know what's with you Seinfeld
you want those pictures and kids to open
the book up and is that what gets you
going Seinfeld and I think that's what
gets too many of the left going in terms
of discussions of sexual activity with
children and just like that I don't
believe in Slippery slopes we we fall
off cliffs morally and just like that
this two past two weeks it's now a tenet
of a major political party in this
country to promote sex talk
with young children in secret in school
in schools and and to me that's not left
right this is a radical Marxist agenda
they want to tear us away from any
competitor to their Revolution
tear us away from religion from family
from private entities business
and your biology and and and sexuality
is traditionally understood and they
want to tear that away and put all of
that into a mix that they will impose
when convenient they'll tell you what
you're going to be and because you have
to rely on them because it's you're just
the Cog in the revolution and anything
that gets in the way of that any
tradition or by even biology they
they're able to do they want to destroy
this is these are dangerous
revolutionary times using the word ropes
fear the that figure it's not it's it's
not inappropriate yeah well and I want
I'll take it even further and be more
clear about it it's not just that they
want to have these conversations about
sex with children that will be bad
enough that will be a problem in and of
itself but they want to normalize
perverted sexual behaviors to children
in secret it's in secret so I I I think
um I actually think schools should teach
religion I think there should be like
religious studies that's not to say they
should tell kids you should be this
religion they should just be like as
part of our social studies class like
we're going to learn about various
religions but to the extent that they're
allowed to do it I wonder because you
can't have you can't teach the Bible in
these schools so I I jokingly tweeted I
half jokingly was like we should have
religion studies kids have questions
teachers teachers should be allowed to
give answers if a kid sees the the
crucifix or a rosary or something on the
desk well then the teachers should be
allowed to give classroom instruction on
Christianity right well of course the
left would flip out if that was the case
then I added we should also teachers
should also tell the kids to keep it a
secret from their parents like that's
just unheard of well I don't think the
schools are capable of doing that the
left would never allow it to happen and
you know my view is that you have to
think about you uberizing education that
you find out who's available to give the
your children the instruction they need
you may not be able to do it through
your own home schooling program but you
have individuals out there who say you
want this taught you want a third grade
education for your child pay me for
three months and we'll get it done on
under your supervision and guidance and
you'll know what was being taught
because the public schools unless they
were validly conservative there's an old
conservative
truism that says any organization not a
validly conservative becomes left over
time that's the thing and that's true
especially about this it's they become
radical the opposite of conservative is
radical the whole liberal thing has been
over utilized and you made that point
about going after kids I don't see that
as a left thing I see that as a child
predator thing and I think child
Predators saw that they could they could
weasel their way in with the left they
tried it by doing the lgbtp thing the
left rejected that initially and they
were like no no now you've got the map
thing minor attracted persons people who
want to go after kids no you're not
going to be able to accomplish that with
conservatives who have a moral
foundation around sanctity the only
option is to get people on the left to
agree without God anything is possible I
like that you mentioned care In fairness
and what it actually means and how
they're maybe misinterpreting it because
if you see a starving child and you
think well the way I can be care about
this kid is to give them food every day
you create a dependent cycle a good
another good way to be care about that
kid is to teach them how to fish now
that kid can go and take care of himself
now what's the real sort of care is it
to feed that kid every day and make
basically a slave out of them to you or
to teach them how to become independent
both people their teeth will tell you
that both of them are types of caring
but getting too emotionally invested in
I think is where things can start to get
twisted well so when you're you need a
combination when dealing with a child
right so for example the responsibility
of the parent is to provide for their
child and feed them but also as you
mentioned ensure that when they become
an adult they are capable of providing
for themselves uh that said I think when
you look at Karen fairness as I
mentioned earlier you can call anything
caring or anything fair it's what they
do all the time I mean look at their
like tautological reasoning around the
normalization of perverse Behavior Love
Is Love what does that actually mean
that sounds very caring that sounds very
fair but it doesn't actually mean
anything you haven't explained why this
is behavior that we should accept yes
sex they're like sex is on the internet
so we need to tell kids about it early
we care about them you know if you
really care about your kids don't show
them the sex these things are a
radicalization tool you do not give them
to Children check this out real quick
this is from June 5th 2019 human events
no Snapchat love definitely does have an
age oh my gosh so they go to mention
that uh so this is Ashley Saint Claire
who noticed that on Snapchat there was a
sticker that said love has no age and
everyone immediately was like yo it does
it's over 18. like what is this there's
lots of types of Love firstly there's
eight types of Love according
that is not for children we get it
there's like child life no that's
actually it it's it's interesting you do
mention the different kinds of love
because our culture we just use one word
for it and I think part of the flaw here
is that we have taken this idea of love
in the sense of selfless giving and
willing the good of the other person and
we can play related it with Arrows with
uh the desire for sexual pleasure the
reason why I didn't want to derail into
this philosophical argument is it was
literally about lgbtq Pride the stickers
on snapchat was about lgbtq issues and
included love has no age yikes all right
so they're not talking about platonic
love we're talking about Agape the love
of the community they're it's like you
don't know there's different ways to
they're not they're not they're talking
about people who want to get married to
each other that's erotic love Eros is
what it's called yeah right so we I
don't we don't need to well they're
they're using the word love to get you
to trick you into thinking that it's
about like familial love no they aren't
it's not love in the metaphysical sense
yes for sure you're you're you you you
love to talk about loves different forms
that is immaterial here to what we're
talking about when you're talking about
lgbtq we're talking about issues of
people who want to get married and have
relationships with each other one of the
words in there is bisexual
when they say for lgbtq positive
branding love has no age there's no
reason to elaborate beyond that we know
what they're saying I agreed agreed well
I mean you have familial love your
mother loves you as a child when you're
born that's but that's not how they mean
well it's a different kind of they're
abused they're twist that's the problem
I mean you said it clearly that word is
too vague
love is too vague it's stupid the Greeks
had eight different types of it why
don't we well you know getting back to
the issue of the uh the focus on the
sexualization of children
at the left in my view the organized
left the extremists left I'm talking
about liberals I don't say think
liberals hate children but the organized
revolutionary left hates children they
hate childhood they have no use for it
other than as a prop for more government
and more Revolution so what else would
you if you hated children what Would You
Do Well you traumatized them with sex
talk
you'd kill them in the womb yep you do
all sorts of things that the left is
doing and it and it's and to the degree
they talk about childhood it's about
collectively raising children it takes
the federal to raise a child uh this is
this is not a child friendly uh
philosophy uh this radical video it's
fundamentally anti-family thanks for
checking out this segment from the Tim
cast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there